during her 16 minutes interview about
film actress stormy Daniels she revealed
intimate details of her alleged affair
with Donald Trump very intimate details
yeah yeah good ooh by the way we've been
I've been working with a theater group
yeah I've been taking this crowd to
classes for weeks now working on that
well time to no stormy Daniels did
reveal very intimate details about her
physical relationship with the president
apparently during climax Donald Trump
shouts Donald Trump store McDaniels did
have a few other startling revelations
about Trump for example Trump apparently
has - comb-overs so
what what I think they got it
Anna mine I know but I wanted to
pantomime did Anna and a man in the
audience set out loud
oh no we all were thinking it yeah I'm
just one of them had one of them had the
courage to say it yeah this is cool
thanks to her interview with adult film
star apparently story Daniel 60-minutes
had its best rating in a decade in a
decade yeah which explains next week
segment ron jeremy investigates steel
tariffs he's very knowledgeable yeah
Paris
you